при продовжують пізнавати суть
цих витрат на українські землі та
споживаємо щоб 25000 заміських і вид
права на той світ
це не нехай
а4 то
а4
[музика]
у нас
[сміх]
[музика]
[оплески]
звичайно коли-небудь я повернуся я повернуся
не не тихенько постукавши я повернуся
нормально на білому коні через п'ять хвилин
знаєш російський світ з голови 3 bastille
комп з диким ви б ти скільки
не
нам [ __ ]
по червоній площі
проходить колона основних бойових танків
т-72 бета
командує парадним розрахунок ним капітан
коротше ми повинні були там дійде треба
їхати не доїхали коротше
поки не раз товариш майор з'їв ти пацан
калоріями засіла нахуй цю до рук від не
від нього бачив одну річ
ось і блювота вбив
колечко був і підора
це летить і такого етапу вилетить чи
ракета
бавовна бавовна бавовна бавовна лапу чекала
тебе все немає ран будуть хлопки потім
овації, що переходять у бурхливі оплески
товариші
[музика]
за це піднімуся я курити в Москві є
такі клуби чорного диму ну за ніч я
забув підпалю 8 у мене канави рити
як люди метушаться пожежі проїжджають ну
люди в шовку очі вже вилазить вони у
мене все по проколу
дев'яти річок та ікони бігають метушаться
намагаються руками згасити він уже сидухи
злодії та добра те що закінчується
добре якесь супер і сторони погріб
уникайте оптимізм будуть я давно
символізм ще при зливі бригадою сгу
relocate
рей сарай
вечеря розмірі руси ще починай палати я
теж переживаю розумію я зазвичай пишу
навіть коліс
я зайшла
шанджела анжелка привіт
зрозумій зайченята експреса перемог і
g почали його вигляд
любить 1
[музика]
delfa
і
[музика]
[оплески]
так надовго ми раділа анжеліна джолі
в таїться до будинку зельва через те що
оренда квартир у львові ну просто
космос звук сира для молот означає
намету байти девід мова але
він коштуватиме 5 валин дівчина будемо шкіри і в
вашу мати
їжа на кухню роботи чай про
сектор його but if кам'яний ліс
затопчемо арки в нашу праву
тут послані за них теж
[музика]
україну вітри могли
тут
брат за брата 2
[музика]
хто такі коти
я crazy on the
рахуй а
що трактора не було вин у бою
а про
смерті ворога
боже такому українському місті безплтано
чий
звичайно принти україни сочі ж кубань
теж
транець траві to moldova
абхазія це грузія чувака все ж таки тебе
продовжуємо стрибати, а не буде
вони швидко подонок шахрай шахрай просто
подонок аніме сволота путін і паросток
виправдовується так і називається
підарасіна
тут
за
[музика]
розділ 6
arata повний
[оплески]
[музика]
опитування
а це все
[музика]
ну навіщо їсти м'ясо з картоплею ну з'їсти
то оселедець та й там із рибою але навіщо ти
на ніч разом з цієї бульби джош м'ясо та
лягаєш спати
аналог фіксикам відкриваємо варення беремо
пакет зав'язуємо
відрізаємо шматочок
можна більше
ось весь вміст
показували
вийшло куйня
[музика]
але
а я зараз вам покажу звідки на Білорусь
готувалася напад слава українці
все зрозуміло добре риється пощастило полями
то це йому всіх у льві про всюди і
куди застуду виходу пику дурню б не
забувати орочий вибачте будь ласка як
нам з львів на москву але в чергу
чи . мені ок
поїздом так він і варіант ви не знаєте
70 друзів за пом'ятою це маршрутка не
танку обряду аж до них від його спить
кинути на маску
[музика]